my dad when he said okay you're gonna go
to you step you're gonna get a football
scholarship okay well you're gonna do
this and you're gonna go to the pros
okay you're gonna go to you gonna you're
gonna be an all-pro and you're gonna go
to Pro Bowl okay you're gonna win a
Super Bowl he told us that week we got
ready to play Patriots are undefeated
you already won the game son it's
already done you're gonna win the Super
Why likey he'd never said if in that
grew and I remember it going wow I never
said it again he truly always said when
which I don't know if he knew what he
was doing I don't think I don't think
he'd knew consciously what he was doing
but he programmed would by always
telling me when in my head if there's
something I want when it happens it's
not if it's gonna happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense the fantastic the wonderful
Michael Strahan is on the show today he
is somebody that I've known for a really
long time I actually met him in New York
we were doing an awareness campaign
together and and we you know we he's
just a really friendly guy so anytime
that we've seen each other after it
always feels very it always feels very
warm and and like we've known each other
for much longer than we really have or
know each other much better than we
really do so I was so excited that
Michael was able to finally come talk to
me I've been asking for a while but my
goodness what doesn't Michael do of
course he went from being in the NFL won
a Super Bowl ring was an amazing player
with a list of accomplishments inside of
the NFL and and and and all of the poor
quarterbacks that he tackled in his day
but what I found and of course now he's
on TV and is like a fascinating TV
personality that you know is just the
happy bubbly smiley guy with the cute
little gap in his teeth that entertain
entertains us in the morning on GMA and
amongst many of the other shows that
he's a part of but what I found
really interesting and surprising was
his level of awareness for the power of
the mind and how he's used it in his
career to improve as a person and
improve his what he's capable of doing
with the mind and simple things like not
using the word if but using the word
when and the lessons that he learned
from his dad and his mom also he he
lived in Germany and the fact that he
was he only played football his senior
year of high school and got a
scholarship to go to college for it was
it's just amazing his level of
dedication once he commits to something
is really impressive and and then of
course that magical power of belief that
he's going to do it and it's not a
matter of if it's a matter of when so
fantastic fantastic human Michael I
really hope that you get as much from
this conversation as I did
please enjoy thank you for coming
Michael of course whenever your name
comes up I always love to tell the story
about when we did the awareness campaign
yeah and we were in New York here for
the launch and there was five of us in
the campaign and one didn't show up to
dinner and we were standing there
talking yeah and you said you know I've
had a real job this isn't a real job and
he said another thing that I've said so
many times in my life afterwards because
it's so true you said I got to eat
dinner anyway yeah and I was like that's
so right and the amount of times I've
used that in my life where I think to
myself what would I what should I do and
then I go you know I got ate dinner
anyway I might as well go work a little
and PR and eat at the same time you know
in it it's sometimes you gotta figure
out a way to psych yourself up into
doing stuff because as you know when
you're constantly around people and all
energy it takes a lot of your energy to
to like walk in the room and and have
all these conversations coming your way
and like doing your thing but I always
look at it as a way of gratitude because
at one point I always wanted what I have
and now that you have it don't complain
about it because I've just seen that so
much people want success people want to
be great at something but when you're
great at something if you want it or not
comes a lot of responsibility so don't
get the responsibility and everything
that comes with that job or that that
that clout or whatever certain people
search for you get it and then all of a
sudden you forget mm-hmm like you
started to take it for granted and you
could never do that because before you
know you look up it'll be gone again
what was your real job you said that was
my real job was my real job trust me
getting beat up in it for me wasn't even
the games I could gain for the fun part
as the amount for a minute guys say they
didn't play they pay you for practice
which is so true but training camp is
what I hate it the summer stuff right
yeah that I had no idea it went like
that what everyone what it what you guys
cuz I just thought home man started
dating Aaron and I thought oh this is
great 14 games is a quick season it's
not like Nascar where you're out there
for 40 weeks a year which is crazy I
mean that's good 40 weeks a year is
insane and you know football's not quite
that and a lot of people wonder why
don't they play more games like
basketball more games like baseball
because physically I don't it's
impossible to do a guy hates playing on
Sunday and then having to have the
turnaround play on Thursdays tough
enough so you know training camp I hated
because you're sleeping in a dorm room
bed and you got to push two baths
together to make them even suitable to
fit especially for you yeah and think
you'll have to lay across the busy they
follow the same from when you put them
together guys your dude talk okay you do
tall and and then you have to practice
twice a day to everything is also
scheduled your meal time your practice
time your rehab time I love the
structure of it but I just did not like
wake it up in the morning so early and
going to practice you put
on these shoulder pads that are still
wet inside from the day before watch in
Italy are they yours at least they were
- okay just so I don't want to lay on
the ground and get my pants and legs wet
and cold again and then you have to
start running into people yeah I don't
feel like hitting anybody don't why
don't you say that during the season
when you were looking at people like
Aaron because people today because that
was fun
there that is fun being in the game is
like oh that's the only thing I'm a mr.
guys number one thing I miss is the
camaraderie around the guys you know in
locker room and all that other than that
the only thing I miss from football is
like that game day you walk out in there
80,000 people screaming and you feel
like a gladiator you literally feel like
a gladiator well you guys kind of art
yeah yeah in a lot of ways a modern day
and but I think that is the only thing I
miss I don't miss the practice stuff I
don't miss the sword is I don't miss you
know a lot of the different things that
you have to do but I do miss that and
all those things I hated about it
whenever I have to do something they're
not necessarily feeling so great about
doing always think you know what this
beats the alternative get out of bed and
go to work get out of bed and go do this
go do that you have to you know what it
beats the alternative and it is what you
did before you got you in this position
and embrace it don't run from it like
enjoy it perspective yeah perspective
what other things did football give you
as perspective I think I'm very in tune
with like people and and and teamwork
and how to get the best out of people
and make people feel valuable and
comfortable because everybody does have
a value and I had I've always been
growing up and you know Germany I was
always the kid it was cutting the grass
I was a kid who was moving the furniture
of the kid who was doing I'm cleaning
the dishes or cleaning off your table
always the person who was unseen like
people wake up is just kind
done you don't appreciate the person who
does it and it's always been focused for
me and I can't help myself with just in
my brain my DNA that I want to make sure
that everybody is a part of what I do or
a part of like the building from the
janitor to the guy who's who the
security guy that they feel seen because
they're as important as anybody else
because if there's no security that's
dangerous for everybody if you go in and
everything else around there's a mess of
nobody's cleaning up you're like what's
going on everybody work together
everybody has value football taught me
to show everybody that you appreciate
what they bring in their value and and
everybody may not seem as important on
the totem pole when you when you look up
and down on the hierarchy of an
organization but you still need that
person to do their best so we're very
important for me to talk to a rookie as
it was for me to talk to a guy who's
been on a team as long as I had in there
it's very important for me now to talk
to the guy who's the cameraman or the
security guy or my buddy Kenny who is
our janitor at the studio than it is for
me to talk to the other anchors and I
think that that ability to kind of go
between people all came from football
and I think it's helped me and my career
now you know not just that GMA but in my
own office in my own home and everywhere
you talked about Germany and you said
they you'd be the one that mode and you
were kind of invisible but first talk
about being in Germany I I had no idea
that you lived in Germany and you looked
there for how long yeah we would I moved
there when I was nine and my parents my
parents I moved there when I was nine my
parents didn't move back into I was an
NFL for like seven years what did he
move back to I was a 28 so you was born
in Texas of born in Houston but I grew
up I spent a lot of time in Maryland
it's been most of the time here in the
States at Fort Bragg North Carolina
military yeah he was the 82nd Airborne
Division paratrooper all that jazz and
then when I was nine we hightailed it to
Mannheim Germany and my dad was baby
81-85 he retired
and then stayed in extra 81 84 then he
retired state 15 more years in Germany
and German electively just because like
electively did it love didn't mind I'm
the youngest of six so you know my
brothers and sisters were all there then
they would eventually come back and go
back and my oldest brother still lives
in Italy to this day really and my other
brothers have lived from the Netherlands
to Italy to Germany to Yugoslavia to
Czechoslovakia they've been everywhere
do you think that that kind of exposure
to other cultures and adapting played a
role in big time you know it taught me
to get along with people no matter what
I don't care where you from I don't care
what your religion is I don't care if
you're poor if you're rich it doesn't
matter to me people are people and when
you're a foreigner in someone else's
country it teaches you to be more
sensitive to what other people's culture
is and understand people a little bit
better be a little bit more forgiving
and and that was great about growing up
in Europe I got a chance to see the
world well the kid so now I come back
here and it's like okay I can get along
with anybody because I've kind of had to
growing up unless you want it to just
kind of be that that that crazy
foreigner who just comes over and think
they're gonna just drop their culture on
us over here in our country who wants to
be that guy so it really taught me being
on a military base being around the
families of soldiers who are even from
all different parts of the country here
you have to learn to get along with
everybody and I'm innately like shy when
I'm not doing like TV stuff and
everything I also say I'm just walking
down the street people they might way
you know how to put inside I kind of
cringe I don't think people believe Wow
weird is that have to do with the scene
part like feeling you had mentioned that
you feel scene and does that mean you
don't want to be seen on some don't
wanna be see I want to be seeming I want
to be seen when I don't want to be seen
I don't want to be seen
it's pretty tough because you're
striking six foot four or five yeah
you know though strong line from the
teeth they see the teeth and I think
they're like a tattoo it's like I gotcha
yeah it's like smile for me it makes it
was you I'm like do they do that oh
absolutely
oh absolutely but yeah it is kind of
that I think kind of when I played
football I my play football I was seven
years old
I played when I was seven and eight and
in Germany I mean in North Carolina in
my first year seven years old I was a
really good player I cried the entire
game I didn't cry because I was hurt I
didn't cry because I didn't want to be
there I loved it I cried because
whenever I would make a play the parents
would clap and cheer and say my name it
bothered you know it's weird
is this something had to unravel in your
life yeah I had to me then you know I
get to college and it's like okay this
is kind of get used to it because
college was different for me because we
moved to Germany and on it I was more
European and I was American so to come
German a little bit like I can you
hungry I can get you food you drink say
like you know how are you it's nice to
be here hello be gates hey how are you
that was it but it was a but it's it I
cried because I didn't like the
attention and then this kind of kind of
snowball because only I didn't play
football growing up am i singing your
high school with only you're playing hi
I can't believe that you played senior
year and got drafted from one year or
like you went it you got a scholarship
one year I was lucky right but serious
enough is that what you'd say till today
while you're still working in a whole
nother profession I'm just lucky baby no
humble I am lucky truly I didn't go to
school for anything I'm amazed I'm not
living with my parents right now like in
the basement of their house or something
I what did you actually get it what did
you actually I want to go to college for
actually what the comma for psychology
really yes I love it I love psychology
but then they like get
these papers and I'm like figure that I
can write I just don't want to write all
these papers so that I went to business
management which both things have kind
of played into the hands of what I do
now and but I love school I love
learning I had was just so green and raw
like I came do states I didn't know what
the heck was going on
in my first year I wanted to quit like I
hated Texas I miss my family miss my
friends I was ready to go back after my
first semester and my dad basically
looked at me I said what do you do your
family and friends in Texas or in
Germany yeah my whole family with the
journey my uncles were the only ones in
Texas why did you why did they did they
send you back to Texas my dad when I was
a senior in high school well go back to
when I was 13 I was not act necessarily
the most active kid I was active with
the fork eaten pretty yeah I was pretty
active with the fork so I had a nickname
which I didn't know what it meant but it
was Bob and I'm not thinking is my
brother's gave it to me I'm gonna
youngest their buddies call me Bob I'm
feeling good like oh I got a nickname
someone cool guys and we were running
they jump they're jumping over fence and
I'm having trouble getting over the
fence and one of the friends helped me
over he go you know what we call you Bob
I mean booty on back
what yeah like you got a big old butt
yeah honey on back Bob big old butt Bob
I'm like funny story now but how did
that make you feel then like horrible
like I cried I'm 13 year old boy
thinking I'm cool I said they break me
down so I cried over that but it was I
literally decided at that point I okay I
can't I don't want to be Bob anymore so
I bought the Jane Fonda workout VHS
tapes us where are you because Jane
Fonda come on Jake files legendary so I
bought I didn't have those two spandex
and stuff but I had to be a chesty I
gravitate toward doing the leg lifts and
like
back in but side lifts from my butt and
then I bought the Herschel Walker
workout book because Herschel Walker was
coming on University of Georgia he was
like the man and I started doing
push-ups and sit-ups and I would watch
TV so I'll say I'd watch dynasty or
something and the commercial breaks I
would do push-ups sit-ups and do my Jane
Fonda leg lifts and do crunches then
there's programmer come on I'm out watch
and then every commercial break and
after months of this my dad said you
know what we'll work out together
because he was a boxer all army boxer
and everything else so we went to the
gym we started going to the gym when I
was 13 and when I was 16 he said you
know what let's send you to Houston
you're gonna stay with your uncle you're
gonna get a football scholarship and I'm
and I was naive I was like to color my
shirt so breathe I was like okay all
right no idea what the heck I would do
it I watched football on TV at that
point I hadn't played in years before
you know high school so I went back to
Houston stay with my uncle art who had
played seven years an NFL and he would
take me in the front yard and slap me
around and showed me different stuff I
had no idea what he was talking about
went to high school didn't know a
quarterback sack was like important I
didn't know I could just have us no idea
we just run around we've got the ball I
guess that's who I go get and I had one
scholarship to Texas other do you
realize how crazy that story is I'm
telling you I'm a lucky man I don't look
he lucky man
yeah but luck doesn't get you to do leg
lifts and get the videos and do push-ups
and sit-ups during commercial breaks
when you're watching TV
does that wait you know it was a great
lesson I look back now though you know
what it was it was something I think
about now and you could change anything
you want is there something you don't
like change it it's something you don't
like change it and for me that was the
first moment in my life I realized I
didn't like being called Bob I didn't
like
being heavy like that so I changed it so
if there's any circumstances in my life
now that I don't like I make a decision
a conscious decision to change it and
and some a Hayek said something to me
one time which I always think about as
well so you cannot complain about
something you're not trying to change
yeah I was like whoa
so I I think back it was kind of like
that mentality I couldn't go oh man they
called me Bob and then complain about it
not changing it yeah I make a conscious
effort yeah has that um I can relate to
a story like this when I was a kid I was
a little chubby and my dad made fun of
me why and I didn't all put it together
until recently but it's always been
something that I attached mentally to
like I I
I've worked out ever since and but
that's a little bit of a scar like it's
what would be called like a attachment
bond or trauma bond to something that
happened and realizing it is important
that you're like oh wow that's where
that comes from but that stuff doesn't
go away that repeating cycle of thought
of like oh don't be Bob right or don't
be is that that work out now to this day
like I work out and I stay on it and I
eat right and I do all the things that
even with my schedule I always make time
to work out because you don't want Bob I
will squeeze that time in there because
I don't want to be Bob and if I don't
work out for a day or two I'm like oh
boy
something's off like I just you look in
the mirror look in the mirror to look at
your button your legs Bob back yeah
exactly one AB I used to have is no
longer there but I am so conscious of it
now of not um I'm going back and I agree
with you it's like from scar I can't get
rid of
believe me I'm yeah wish I could but I
always go back to that yeah I was like
ten yeah happen you were thirteen
thirteen and I haven't missed working
out ever since yeah but at the same time
it helped me so much in the fact that
when I went to college and in the pros
and everything else I could work out by
myself I didn't need anybody else to
motive
me and and then when I was on the field
in college and in which transferred over
to the probe as well I also had to Ben
tell the okay you know I wanted to quit
when I was a freshman went back home to
Germany
my dad said what are you gonna do cuz I
overstayed the Christmas holiday
thinking he wouldn't notice I hadn't
gone back to school and he's like um
shouldn't you be back at school at that
time like yeah you know you know I'm
being man about man yeah you know if I'm
not going back and he said what are you
gonna do I said we're on the stay here
get a job and he looked at me and said
what are you gonna do and it's like a
light bulb went off in my head that I
can't wait for my mom and dad to take
care of me forever literally that's the
thought then what the red your mom and
dad can't take care of you forever you
have to do something for yourself and I
went back to school it's okay I'm on
football scholarship I have to play
football have to be in school just be
your best at it you got to do it anyway
so I do it kind of yes yes yeah you can
either be half-ass and mediocre or you
could put on just a little bit more
effort and be great
and that really completely changed my
mentality that if I'm gonna do it I'm a
be great at it I'm not going to half-ass
anything and the extra workouts when
everybody else goes home I took pride
and lifting extra weights and running
more when everybody else would go pack
it in when guys were more concerned
about going to get lunch or or hanging
out with you know with their buddies and
doing everything else I was working
because my goal was far beyond just
College my goal was getting out of
college and not saying that I thought I
was gonna be a professional football
player but I just knew that you know
working hard was gonna get me somewhere
I wasn't sure and it got me to New York
got me out of out of college and gave me
a career it's interesting you say my
goal was beyond like your goal went past
college right it was like to get through
so the workout was no big deal
talk about like how I mean like that's
an advanced mindset
you know to have a goal that goes beyond
the immediate and who taught you what we
mean you come from your parents were
into sports military there's a lot of
regiment with all those kinds of things
were where did you get the mindset to be
so driven you know it's crab a bed mat
now I could see it back then I could not
see any iiu for you to ask me that you
know 10 years ago 20 or 15 years ago I
said I have no idea
now I have an idea that subconsciously
it was planted in my brain by my parents
and especially my dad by dad when he
said okay you're gonna go to Euston
you're gonna get a football scholarship
okay well you're gonna do this and
you're gonna go to the pros okay you're
gonna go to you're gonna you're gonna be
an all-pro and you're gonna go to Provo
okay you're gonna win a Super Ball he
told that that week we get ready to play
Patriots are undefeated you already won
the game son it's already done
you're gonna win the Super Why likey
he'd never said if and that grew and I
remember it going wow I'd never said it
again he truly always said when which I
don't know if he knew what he was doing
I don't think I don't think he'd knew
consciously what he was doing but he
programmed would by always telling me
when in my head if there's something I
want when it happens it's not if it's
gonna happen and I am just programmed to
truly believe that everything I did was
go to work out and I don't go into it
thinking it's not and not saying
everything has but if it hasn't to be
honest with you it was a miracle to even
get to the point to where it even got to
the point to where it was benefited in
the first place so it's always a win
conversation for me it's always a win
somebody says something to me I'm like
okay what happens in my head I never
doubt I don't get stressed over stuff
like any work itself out work out for
the positive and it always does
I just don't have a fear mentality of Oh
worry about this and worry about that if
it's gonna happen
no I do it my kids always tell them when
so there's no doubt that's so powerful
because I mean from everything that I
read do you get into paying attention to
like the mind and how it works in
neuroplasticity and subconscious and
retraining your brain repetition all
kinds of different right so you know
that you knew back then but you
definitely know now from watching that
that there's if you can imagine your
brain can't tell the difference between
an event that's happened in your mind
versus a real event yeah
so if you imagine the event to have
already occurred when like your it's not
the if it's the oh yes it's happening
like you imagined it in its finality and
its totality like all the way till the
farthest extent all that's left to
happen is for it to happen to convince
yourself that it happened yeah it and I
truly I speaking of some like
subconscious never sleeves
it never does and I'll never forget in
one year maybe my tenth year in the
league or something having a great
season it's going to the Pro Bowl we go
to San Fran to play the 49ers Steve
Young was still playing man got two
sacks on Steve Young they have ten sacks
on the season we still lost a game and I
go to Arizona we were supposed to play
the Cardinals the next week so instead
of flying all the way back to New York
we just went in a state in Arizona
Tucson and you know Arizona State or
something like that and I went to see a
sports psychologist when our
psychologists kind of I'm the sports
psychologists on didn't know what this
guy was it's not the middle of desert
somewhere be widely why because you know
what I was like god I'm having a great
year but I just didn't feel like it and
in my head I used to try to visualize
and stuff and I visualized myself
beating the offensive tackle and I'm
coming close to the quarterback and
literally I said to him right before I'm
hitting the quarterback before I can see
the complete it it goes black like I
can't finish it in my mind but I mean
yeah I'm still playing well I just
cannot finish it in my mind and it
bothered me so I went to on this
disguise
I didn't mean truck we talks for a while
then he said I'm gonna make you a tape
and lay that he made you this tape and
in his tape is basically uh like your
breathing slowing you down slowing down
your breathing just focusing relaxing
your body and this like a very powerful
tape he said I want you to listen to
this tape every night before the game
whatever it may be and I said well
understood and I said don't worry about
falling asleep your subconscious never
sleeps that's what I'll sleep with a TV
on now he's sleeping the TV on now I
don't do it whatever is on that program
you know it's being programmed program
and especially in those lower brainwave
states of theta and Delta especially
theta state when you're going into Delta
and coming out which Delta's the deep
sleep that's your that's your so it's
like a hypnotherapy kind of session like
that's where you really get the deep
subconscious programming smart and
that's what he was in and that really I
so I would listen to the state fall
asleep wake up I had in my opinion and
it's funny because my buddy Harvey
Sanders said to me Michael that was the
greatest game ever played in Arizona I
said you know what Harvey
in my opinion of any game I've ever
played in my life and I have some
crediting the greatest game I ever
played
I felt so powerful is so clear and so
free and energetic and that tape was the
greatest career change for me and got to
the point I wore the tape out but I
listened to it so I said like a classic
tape wasn't a CD or cDNA myself here
classic so is my first tape I'm talk
about Jays father VHS tape I'm talking
about a regular like record to update
but yeah it was a regular tape I wore it
out and I've used it so much and thought
into this day I couldn't if I got
something big coming up I can sit there
I'm lay there in bed at night for good
and I could talk myself through it now
talk myself through it and relax it just
it's just the most amazing and just a
little like all the times I'm going to
do something show me the thing where you
put your hand like this and somebody
could pull
apart but then he said do like that he
pulled my hand apart then he said
picture a solid solid ring of steel
unbreakable steel he tried to pull it he
you cannot pull it apart but if I should
say let me pull your fingers apart
there's nothing you can do to stop me it
was the most powerful thing and before
I'm going to do some big event if I
speak in front of people because I do
get nervous of still doing stuff of
people I think I don't but I do a lot of
times something I'm really nervous I
will I will do like this and picture
solid rings or still like you've got
this you are you know yeah and it just
takes me back to that place I need to be
wait so they need to stop saying picture
everyone their underwear that's not
productive no not because some people I
don't want picture I'm good yeah be good
some people might not be wearing on a
rat it's really weird that everyone it's
funny you mentioned that you had such a
great game in Arizona after playing that
tape whenever I think about when I won
in Japan mmm the IndyCar race that I won
right before I went I watched the secret
and I always think about that till today
have you seen the secret have you read
it or watch well there was a oh man I
think it was a DVD I don't think I'm
think it was I think it was a DVD and I
yeah yeah and and I watched that before
I went to Japan and it's all it talks
about is focusing on what you want and
being able to attract it the law of
attraction and funny enough then
fast-forward like ten years I get a
direct message from Ron de Bruyn who
wrote the book and yeah and and she sent
me a message on Twitter and said hey I'm
coming out with the 10 year anniversary
of the secret and I'd like to send it to
you and I thought sketchy like you know
normally like sure you're Ron de bruyne
sure you are exact and so I was replying
to her saying oh yeah you know I'm happy
to go buy your book from you just no
problem I'm really you know love what
you've done and she's like no I'd love
to send it
like oh god Haley what's the what's the
work address you know it's the PIO box
so then I gave it to her sure enough
sent it signed it was really her and I
was like wow and so I told her that you
know but has she heard that you I told
her when he she had sent that message
thinking okay if this really is her
she'll you know want to maybe hear this
story but she didn't know that before
listen to my inner thoughts maybe she is
and that's what she's very powerful yeah
extremely powerful well you know what
else helped me to amazingly enough for
this with people who laughed I did the
movie The Matrix yes
you know why that movie help me because
neo fought the entire time and he would
think okay he's getting better he's
getting further long and get further
along his belief of himself but then
they got to the end and he gets shot and
they think he's dead and the female
carry she goes over and she kisses him
and says what she said to him I love you
by kissing him and then he wakes up and
when Laurence Fishburne looks up and
they shoot at him again he goes no his
belief he completely believed in herself
and he takes the bullets that he just
drops him and I'll never forget that
year I was like you know what that's a
sack record gear I think yeah because I
watched a movie later than everybody
else come and everybody else to enjoy
something I'm hard-headed I'm like it
can't be that good outweigh to my time
being all stubborn second and I
literally remember they came you know
what why limit yourself why not believe
it you can do something extraordinary so
if you get one sack usually get a sack
in a game you go okay got a sec
pressures off off the hook off do my job
I'm good my kid just won a game that's a
great season with 17 I've done my job to
like okay I forget one why can't get to
my can I get three why can I get for ya
like I stop limiting my set one and it
was so powerful to in that movie like
spark a light bulb went off because of
that movie and it's just all these
little thing that
a long life if you really pay a paid
enough attention there are so many
lessons that you can learn from things
that you see people you observe and I
found that to me people were successful
and more so than successful or happy
I'll have a sellout of the same
attributes I'll have a lot of the same
way that they approach thing that has a
certain way of looking at different
things I don't see problems when I see
things
uh-huh I truly don't look and go god I
got this problem driving me crazy or
this person I just looked at and that
just calmly think of try to figure out a
solution and to me that's interesting
it's like trying to put together
different puzzles everyday kind of
flying solution or whatever issues may
pop up so not everything is meant to go
perfect right you said the line
everything follows through not
everything gets seen to you know the way
you want it to go how do you know when
to this is something I had to learn
letting go versus quitting especially
with retiring yeah was wrapping my head
around that concept because I didn't
feel like I was quitting I was kind of I
don't really want to do it anymore
and so this letting go versus quick how
do you know when to let go I think
that's a hard thing the hardest thing
for an athlete especially we don't have
careers that go for 50 60 years
and I wouldn't want yeah and you're not
thinking about like there's this
interesting dynamic within sports and
maybe you feel the same that you don't
number one you don't talk about being
done yeah because number one you're not
really thinking about it and you're
pretty young you're also you don't want
to plant a seed in anyone else's head
that you're not fully committed and you
also don't want to do the job if you're
not fully committed so it's like a light
switch it's like when it happens it
happens because you don't want to be out
there on the field with potentially
getting hurt you don't want to cheat
your teammates you don't want to but you
and you and so you'd and you don't want
it you're not talking about retiring so
there's this interesting suddenness to
retiring from sports that doesn't happen
and like there's no
not like I'm retiring when I'm 60 you
know from been here for 40 years there's
no a lot of times you get retired a lot
of guys aren't ready to go and they get
retired I think you and I were very
fortunate in the fact that we retired
ourselves yeah and my first coach Earl
Leggett said they said he missed coach
Howie long and he was a my pain the best
defensive line coach in the history NFL
without him out of lasted maybe two or
three years on athletic ability alone
he gave me knowledge of football he
really taught me what I did not learn in
high school because I didn't play it and
growing up at in college he was the
master and he said hey tell you now he
said two things to me and how we wish
would repeat to each other because there
Earl must be extremely proud and
laughing in heaven rest in peace he said
if you listen to me and do everything I
tell you you will be more successful and
more rich than you ever imagined thank
you everybody was true anybody worked
you he work you like a dog he worked you
harder than any coach I've ever had to
weigh the coach of glad you had not you
have that you had it's kind of hell yeah
but he was the bench I couldn't had it
without him I have a career without him
but he also said you know what you never
know when it happens but when it goes
when you game go it goes quick it could
go and can't you can go to the middle to
see that you can go at the end but when
it goes it goes quick and for me when I
retired I wasn't crying at Mile retired
then I was freaking happy but I put
everything I had into it
I remember thinking every practice okay
go out here and go hard and practice
your bodies 36 years old it may break
but if it does make sure it breaks going
hard instead of out here you know taking
it easy you know half-assing safe don't
no half-assing and you'll never strap a
helmet on there
put on another shoulder pad ever again
think about that thought you never have
to do it again so put everything into it
why you have to do it so we have no
regrets and I was so afraid after we won
the Super Bowl and Giants offer him for
me to come back definitely enhance the
salary everything else and I said no
because when I was afraid that I knew it
was going and I felt had I'd gone back
it was gonna go pretty quick I knew at
some point taking me too much keep up
with within and stay where I needed to
be to compete at that level physically
physically yeah it's brutal I mean
seeing as did I was I just did not want
to give another pep talk I didn't want
to jump up and stomp out speeches I
didn't want to take my fingers up
anymore I just didn't want to do it and
it was very sudden we won it well you
couldn't after the Super Bowl you can
say la doesn't play tomorrow
I feel like yes but after we wanted it
had a chance to settle in I said what
else there left to prove I put
everything I had into it no regrets
whatsoever I'm not going to cheat the
game like you said I'm not going to go
back when I'm I headed all retired just
for a few bucks because there's more
value to me in going out on top and
there's more value to meeting going out
knowing that you know what I went out on
my terms and when you're in a locker
room and I saw Justin Tucker earlier
today we were laughing because they it's
called me old man was I'm old man how
are you so old I'm like I'm 36 in every
other life that's all but in football is
not but we had a big laugh because I
told them so many things about being
older but an older player and and and
all those different things that he
literally called me after I retired I
said I don't know how you did this for
so long and and and but they all I try
to teach all these young guys the same
thing that I mentality that I had called
hard as you can't get as much as you can
out of it
then when it's over so over you have no
regrets because it works you to have
regrets
you didn't give it everything you had
how does that roll into knowing when to
let go of other things that aren't quite
so sudden
right they're like a little more blurry
it's a little bit a little bit harder to
go I mean it could be everything from a
relationship to a business that you try
and start and you're like try and try
and try and like how what are the signs
I think relationships are probably the
hardest one because relationships in
some way shape or form involve you but
they also involve other than I think in
relationships I know for me in the past
you're in a relationship with someone
and say that relationship is public in
some way or people because they know you
know who you're with or whatever
it becomes sometimes where you're like
you know what I noticed isn't working
but I cannot try to make it work because
so many people see us together so many
people associate us from being together
it's kind of like I guess we're supposed
to be together now because we were known
to be together it's a weird thing but I
think once you get over there and
realize that is your life you live it
for yourself and I'd rather be a part
and be happy than be miserable together
it's just life to sort to be miserable
with someone you need somebody to
complement you who makes you feel you
know great and happy and I've had to
learn that over the course of imperfect
relationships or imperfect life and when
it comes to businesses and things like
that I've had the opportunity to be
around some smart people credibly smart
people in business and one thing I
noticed things are very emotional when
it go unemotional when it comes to
business business it's not personal
mm-hmm and and sometimes you got to cut
your ties because I found trying to save
certain things there's more tied up into
your ego than it is actually to if it's
supposed to if it really it's gonna make
sense or work and you would have formed
bad money I mean good money behind bad
money in a lot of ways yourself sticking
around and and and trying to solve is
something that you should just move on
from and and you got to be very I found
unemotional when it comes to business
when it comes to negotiating
and that's the approach I've taken an
approach that seems to work and also I
don't know is it stuff everybody's
different
certain people probably a little bit
longer than I me yeah stick with so you
stick a little bit more we don't want
everything to work of course right you
wouldn't start it if you didn't want it
to work but at least in business things
are a little more cut and dry where it's
like okay a plus B is not equally see
right now and so let's move on I mean I
think companies there's a grace period
when you're starting one to go like that
let's give it some thickness right
especially if you believe in one right
there's some magic in the belief and
that might take a little bit of time but
I found that stuff that you really are
passionate about things you believe in
think you really are organic to you tend
to work or have some success in some way
shape or form I think when someone tries
to do something that's a clear out of
character yeah does it fit them
especially if you're trying to sell
yourself as part of the business you
can't really believe in it I think
people now so smart that they know if
you are truly behind something if you
truly believe in something and they know
if you just put on the front I think
people are I think the I think the some
I think the consciousness of culture is
rising
I think we're aware of people's feelings
since this this metaphysical sort of
environment of like energy and feeling
often authenticity from people I think
we're getting more sensitive to being
able to tune into that do you feel like
a great battery and it's funny because
you know being on TV now and I know it
freaks everybody out and it freaks me
out too
yeah how the hell did you Rand on TV
like oh my god no I told you when I saw
you at the show GMA third hour I was
like you are the poster boy for you're
the poster child not boy or girl or
anything not because I really care about
the difference but like you're the
poster child for an athlete that's
transitioned into a whole other field
and done it so well so Bravo well you
know what remember that kid who cried or
but you better see that kid now you keep
that up very hard for me to see that
yeah I'm just coming it's okay you're
being seen kind of working like be like
I'm being seen it's okay yeah I gotta
learn that part that part I have to
learn that that I really have to get
over that over that crutch that was
never really changed my life if I could
could figure that out
there's we all have that that time doc I
got some time you've got time but but I
see you and I and I see that I see that
transition being something that is so
rare so really impressive and it shows
that your values that applied to
football are applying to just something
else and to be honest that's what I hope
for my life is that I want to accomplish
great things in a whole other arena
because I I would love the idea that
whatever was true to me from core
beliefs to work ethic to goals however I
worked my life was I could just pick it
up and place it somewhere else right it
wasn't about that one thing I was just
good at that one thing it's that I'm
good at building something from myself
so I'm just curious how TV became the
one how did it happen and how did it
happen the biggest challenge for me weed
I think the biggest challenge for most
people I essentially just athletes who
come from a certain field it's doing
something different yes because you
especially athletes you get so
associated with one thing yeah and you
get associated with it and then you just
start to believe that it's the one thing
that you do and you do well it's your
safe space it's the only thing you're
supposed to do and the toughest thing
for me was getting over the fact that
I'm more than just an athlete you hear
guys say that now but it's true it's not
just a cliche you have to get in your
head that yeah okay I was an athlete and
I had this great career and but I'm
allowed to have great career and other
things we people almost want to say okay
you had a great career great race car
driver you've had you've had the Good
Fairy juice sprinkled on you in that
career that's enough
and I think for me growing up over see
the night
being a football player thinking that's
what I'm gonna do with my life it just
kind of happened
made me feel like okay that was part of
my life is over now let's get to
something different
Wow look at all these your life is full
of great things out here that I never
knew about so I just I've always gone
into everything very bright eyed but I
did have to get over it took me a while
to get over the fact that I was more
than just a face that people with it
with know from sports and it's weird now
because most people have no idea I play
sports my kids come up to me and moms
come up to me and they're like in the
finna dad sweetie I'll go Giants Michael
great job what you did now they come up
saying oh I saw that cooking segment you
did I'm like dude you were saying dude
talk about football how do we about
cookie but it's a compliment and since
that it's complete transformation of
different onion to a you know going into
a totally different career but it all
happened by happenstance at least to
start I mean I work hard at it but I
just like doing stuff when they would
ask me what I would do interview because
he lived in New York so you were able to
do shows and fill-in even while you were
still work when I was still playing and
they were saying at this thing you want
them to yeah oh my god they're doing
okay many of you
yeah and I even use the interview that's
practice like everybody gets cliche
answers I kind of push the envelope to
try to give more interesting funny yeah
answers to the routine questions
I would also talk to her reporters and
get the door way from you know just the
interviews like them and joke with them
real facts yeah and and I also kind of
learned at the end of my career I didn't
talk only talk like two days a week to
media and I've just I don't know crunk
all these crazy thoughts coming on going
you know if I talk every day then I just
become another player who talks every
day nothing special with that kind of
going to you show up at the the same
club every day you're just another
patron at the club but if you pop in
every once in a while Oh
god it's a bigger deal so I said I'm
Leeteuk Tuesday I wanted to talk
Wednesdays or Thursdays and Sunday that
was it it was kind of like a supply and
demand when it comes to my interview I
think that's how Aaron works it - he's a
low supply item and guy makes them want
it what you say has more legs for sure
it had never hit the cutting room floor
because you cut that you're not gonna
cut it cut all you got this week yeah so
I always looked at that bother you the
media has been using awesome that's a
sleet's of people in general for a long
time how about flipping it back
you control the conversation you control
the time you control everything
and to me it made it might be a little
bit more kind made everybody be a little
bit more polite made everybody be a
little bit more in tune and know that
they better come correct because I may
walk in and say on today I'm answering
three questions I'm not upset kind of
like a game somebody asked me for I say
you get can't count I said three are you
guys thank you other day that may go I'm
answering one question other day I see
Darren talk for 30 minutes I always kept
them off-balance and just doing those
little things kind of give me an idea
Wow
you know what media thinks a media thing
I and then I just kept getting invited
to do stuff in the best damn sports show
oh yeah Beth now I love it that right
there looks like a great training ground
for me because the first time I ever got
a chance like co-host something with a
panel and and kind of be a part of like
a show like that and the best thing I
did with them was my last year or two in
the league I signed the deal contract so
that every Tuesday I would go sit in the
studio by myself with just a camera in
my face and I couldn't see them I could
hear them and to create a banter back
and forth and to be interesting just
what a camera your face without any
visual who you're talking to
it taught me how to move my
my expression in height and highs and
lows in the voice inflection it taught
me how to almost entertain without
seeing what the audience was which it
very much
what I have to do on the daytime show
it's the same thing when I was with
Kelly and now doing you know dealing
with you the Kiki and Sarah it is the
same thing I you know facial expression
when someone's talking they say
something it's like I don't know I love
it I love figuring out all these little
my new things that they make like you're
creating the motion at home creating the
emotion that I'm feeling on my face so
that you're feeling at home yeah because
you did just sit there like this the
whole time and be happiest I hadn't no
one would know pretty advice cuz I do
that a lot they're like whenever I do
things on TV they're be like smile you
got a smile more I'm like okay and then
I sit there like and I have a natural
like frown when I just sit there like I
actually if I'm doing a you know when
you do shots for something they're like
okay give me a serious face give me a
happy face right my serious face was a
smirk because otherwise I look miserable
as hell like I looked horrible and I
realized that in a photo shoot in
England I did there was like a real
serious one and I looked at my my mouth
goes down I'm like oh wow that's just
terrible so that's that's and that's so
visualise the emotion that you want to
create like what other advice do you
have for me all that craziness that in
TV so I'm very lucky I have jobs but I
could be myself
I don't have to be this way on TV and
then I get over here and I got to be a
completely totally different doctor to
now there's one thing delivering the
news because right now I'm every job I
have is so different oh my god didn't
the sports is great with the guy the
minute guys hanging out if we hang out
and talk about football and I feel easy
it's easy it's kind of you know I have
to know my stuff but it's easy with the
guys and we're like dancing bears
because we never know what each other
it's gonna say
and it is all organic the laughter is
organic the comments are organic because
the cold weather you're out there in the
organic but is that that show with all
fresh because every day you have to pay
attention code we don't know what each
other's gonna say they comes across on
TV and we have a respect and a love for
each other like brothers that it comes
across we hang out with each other when
we're not on TV we group text like we
were every day every day
and but then when you go to GMA the
totally different beat it's like series
news but then you got to learn how to
you know switch it up you know now we're
gonna change switch gears then you go to
something a little bit more funny and or
simple or light and then you got to go
back to something a little more heavy
learning how to make the transitions in
the news was hard and when somebody
telling a story and they throw it back
to you and you got to figure out a way
to button up that story and then
transition it to the next story I mean
all these things that look so easy and I
watch the news don't you think about
when you're on it you're like and for
two years at least
I was unlike sweating like a farm animal
scared to death of screwing up and now
like second nature
it's like repetition of things that's
that was the hardest thing about the
news doing daytime is is great because
it's a personality based situation and
you have a good personality that hey
thank you but I just I'm allowed to be
myself and I learned that as many jobs
that can get where I'm allowed to be
myself it's fantastic
where do you feel like you're the most
yourself because if there's one thing to
say like I'm myself on TV and then
that's a whole nother thing when you go
this is where I am the most authentic me
and I feel so good
specific place where are you what are
you doing Bahama who's there is anyone
there
Thomas on the golf course in the Bahamas
on the golf course or literally at home
I get home doing what I'm quiet in a lot
of I come I'm simple I my okay best
place for me is my man cave by myself
for the most part what's in man cave
cars cars cars TV a golf simulator and a
bar what do you like to drink tequila
just straight up mix it up but I kind of
like a straight up on the rock with a
lime okay good well you know why because
when I'm getting ready for Magic Mike
the my trainer she gave me this whole
literally he says what I'm getting ready
for Magic Mike yeah we have what trust
me I've just until my scared to death
that scary but then after stripping once
I would say my traitors like no sugar no
dairy no wheat no alcohol mm-hmm and I
said oh I can do all the other stuff I
gotta have a drink every once a while be
realistic it's just not gonna happen
I make wine and it's the one thing I'm
like yeah yeah I really love it so she
said okay if you're gonna drink anything
tequila on the rocks with the lime you
don't have a soda you could ask add too
if you really wanted to
Bruce it up it so I kind of got into
that vibe but I love tequila this is my
drink but I go to my man cave and it
probably surprised people that I would
literally sit watch TV or I'll just get
in the car and I'll just drive I'm
parking another one I Drive just
something with that solitude to quiet
time and I love cars growing up in
Germany and the autobahns and listening
to the engines and just appreciated cars
cuz I think that they're like art okay
well what's the fastest you've known on
the Autobahn then I mean I'd be dumb to
not press I've ever bid at 109 95 miles
per 195 yes on the Autobahn [ __ ] go
for right now I'd go faster
well let's go yeah I've never been on
them bit of er but I have been over 195
but see if you tell you what I'm not
driving with you
what you expect me to ride with you at
195 but you're not riding with me yeah
why not okay because let me tell you why
see you go with that with Michael
Waltrip Michael Waltrip I could walk if
I did this show way back in the day
what's go the show now you would talk
about there's some thing about all these
things that I've done because I look at
where I am now and I kind of it's cut
there's so many things that I've done
that I forget about people forgotten
about and it was one make my day was the
name of the show make my day so we would
find an athlete find their biggest fan
surprise the fan with the athlete and
then take them to do something together
so Michael watch it was one of the guys
we use we went down commit the young
lady and we went to the track he takes
her on the track I'm the host I'm not
supposed to be on the track but he of
course you want to get in the car I'll
go around with you right up against the
wall like that okay and I'm like okay
this is but then when he hit somebody
look at you buddy hey Travis now looking
at the road I don't do it nah yeah you
guys played too much well it sounds like
we're gonna race each other on the
Autobahn then that that we could do okay
you smoked me but you know how many's at
the rest stop equipment matters
equipment does matter yeah yeah well
we'll leave what is your happy place
where is your calm place where is your
place to be totally you my the most were
think the easiest repeatable scenario
other than just being like you know
something like on a beach somewhere
where it's just beautiful you know and
just having your like feeling the
environment in the saltwater air and
just so much nature so I'm integrated in
nature is to take my dogs for a walk
I just love I've really discovered that
about five years ago where that was my
balance for my life was just I'd love to
see the joy of them running around and
having so much fun in nature and I love
to be in it so I prefer like trees that
cover the top right so you're in nature
like really in the trees so if I can
find paths to walk on where I'm really
in it then it's just like I mean it
sometimes it's so beautiful or I get
such an
feeling of just gratitude like I could
cry just randomly just like wow
life is so fantastic and so beautiful
and I can just be in nature and have
this emotion kind of puts things in
perspective a little bit so a little
nature walk is probably my best I
promise you know living here in the city
it's like I feel bad someday someday
promise him yes we're moving I can't
work like this forever I'm like we're
moving buddy and our mountains are very
genuine Mountain mountains our beach guy
I can do both I think preferably for the
most part warm weather in a beach okay
but I do think you need a place to go
that's like removed from everything I
always love that I should live in
Pennsylvania when I played at one point
yeah and I have to sit out there and
watch the snow fall on the trees and
just do nothing it was the absolute best
to have quiet around you just nature as
you said there's just trees yeah it's
just very peaceful to me yeah and you
know I always think about myself like
this it's like Oh think of gratitude and
I wonder just really quickly with you
how you feel do you ever look and think
about you when you were at an age where
you have no idea what you're gonna do it
your life then you look at your life now
go wow oh yeah I mean it's easy to think
and just like you were talking about
about having an idea like being 10 years
old and racing go-karts something I'm
gonna go to college for engineering so I
can work on my car and then the fact
that I did that and did what I did and
became so well known and so different I
look at that now and I just you know
it's one of a million right yeah and
there's so much gratitude for it going
like that but I do come around to that
very concept of I just believed it was
possible there's no reason why I made it
happen why it happened because when I
came back from England after having
having no job and having no ride for two
years really there's no reason why it
should have worked
I was 19 years old no no hope but for
some reason I had such blind faith
that's what I was called it when I was a
kid
blind faith that it was gonna work I
just knew I needed the opportunity
whatever if I was given the opportunity
I knew that it could be really big I
just knew it could be really big and I
don't know what that looked like but I
just knew it and I knew I had too much
to offer
yeah so that belief is super powerful so
look you have so many things going on
you have your show you have a clothing
line they're coming out in JC Penney's
what's it called yeah we have a clothing
line we bid
it's called collection by Michael
Strahan is our formal wear like suits
ties cufflinks belts you name it we have
MSX which is our athleisure line and
we've had collection for four years or
so it's the number one selling formal
wear menswear Oh done yes I dabbled in
the clothing world that's tough it's a
tough world yeah you also have a show
with a rod coming out show with a rock
off back in the game on CNBC what's the
premise of that show that show we have
the men getting back in the game yeah
well no but it is interesting because we
not only did athletes we did you know
some other celebrities who have had
frame had fortune a lot of a lot of
times have lost it all or a chunk of it
who just need a wreck some want to give
them faith in themselves to get back in
the game and this showed them how to
manage their life life is now because as
we know when you retire a lot of people
retired they didn't save they didn't
plan for the future they've had the
business acumen that to create something
a rod so good at that I mean he's been
investing since he was in his 20s I was
really impressed first when he we did
the first we did one last year and I was
like oh I see and I watched it and I hit
up Alex and I said dude I'll be honest
with you when you came in to do it I
wasn't sure I you were gonna do
absolutely crushed it he is so good and
so we're back in the game we have
Evander Holyfield is one of our guy Ryan
Lochte like we went out and got some
great people who really want to change
their life and it's not a vanity show to
say okay here you know just put these
names
sincerely helping people get back on
their feet and trying to change their
lives and you'll see some tough
conversations when you have to go and
Alex have to sit there and tell this
person is just to being the star and
their wife or their fiancee
you know what can't afford this house
can't afford that car I know you used to
but that's not your life now mm-hmm and
how to get them to accept it that's
change for the better but yet have idea
that what they want to do in the future
and have him help guide them in those
ways and then with you with the mindset
I mean honestly your mindset is so
powerful that's gonna be amazing cute
like to see it well you know what um but
I love that we've both accomplished
great stuff and you know I think that
you know yes I got lucky along the way
too we got to be at the right place at
the right time but you also have to
believe it's possible and you have to
stick it out I'm gonna get harder you
have to get ready to dig dig deeper yeah
no Bob dig deeper so what what I know I
I could feel like we could just go on
and on but maybe you could just give us
maybe what has been your greatest life
lesson so far my greatest life lesson so
far is I always try to remind myself
that what I do is not who I am
what I do is not who I am
which keeps you humble because you don't
think you know everybody's gonna treat
me a certain way and I absolutely get it
I'm gonna be treated as celebrity in
this star I get it but that is not who I
am because they treat me that way
because of what I do and that's why I do
things for myself I don't require a lot
of extra than people and attention and
all these things I try to make my life
as simple and that could be I try to
stay in a in a group of people who are
who keep me grounded would normal in a
lot of ways not not who does
himself in the elevated way and I think
that that's the biggest lessons like
what I what I do is not who I am so I
need to keep those two people separate
even know a lot of what I do is my
personality the thing that other people
see you may bring towards you because of
what you do on TV or whatever is not
reality what life really is well what
you do is not forever so if you wrap
yourself up and what you do and then
that ends who are you it's great I think
for me even in football I could have
played longer and even in his TV stuff I
already know in my head I'm gonna get
out before they get me out before before
they think I should leave nothing scared
me more than overstaying and welcome
that's where I should end then because
I'm pretty sure you need to go greedy
this is better than the gym so I can
have an excuse not to go today
okay Park to start it up again no thank
you so much Michael this is really
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it and also thank you so much
Trevor Hall for the awesome music if you
like what you heard today and you want
to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
[Music]